we are in fact with a linear linear
we've heard the Sam's account what is
your account about what transpired in
today's game uh well I I mean I was
already so tired a few rounds ago that I
was having a hard time uh getting out of
bed and preparing at all in the morning
so uh you know I thought I would I would
play solid today I had something in mind
I thought he would play neither fan I
had something in mind against the E5
against the English attack which is the
line that he usually plays I mean we
played that line in fact a couple of
times in our games
uh but this line with 94 I wasn't
expecting it's it's kind of sharp I
didn't repeat it and I didn't remember
at all the the details I played it
against firusha in the singfield cup
it's quite sharp and um so I didn't
especially prepare for that so I thought
that I would in in that case I can I can
just repeat moves because uh anyway uh
it's uh it's it's uh I was going to play
solid so I thought that he would go E5
and and and then we would we would have
a game but yeah anyway it's uh it's
normal result we were discussing here in
the studio how important the energy
levels are in the last few rounds
especially in a 13 round event what is
your routine usually looking like yeah
it's kind of tough of course as I was
saying it's uh the last few rounds were
were difficult also I had this uh
three games over 90 moves I had one game
with 130 moves and another one with over
100 moves so it was quite uh quite tough
and uh yeah I mean you try to save
energy to sleep well but uh uh 13 Rounds
it's it's quite a lot it's uh it's been
a long time that I didn't play such a
tournament so yeah it was it was an
issue but yeah it's this is the good
part where where all the software and
it's it's over and you get to relax a
bit then here congratulations guys any
questions yeah quick question for you
Lanier first of all congratulations on
your result uh undefeated uh you're
qualified for the World Cup all of those
good things 130 131 move game against
Christopher you is that your longest
game in your chess career oh
I'm not sure I had some some long games
uh
some time ago but I think yeah 130 has
to be I mean if not if not the first uh
it's it's it's a second or something but
yeah I think I'm pretty sure it's it's
my longest game yeah
right because it's too much I mean 90
already feels like you play two games
instead of one but uh yeah but in fact I
know for sure because I never got to
feel like more than two score sheets
right so yeah when I when I saw the
third score sheet I know this is this
has never happened before so that was
the giveaway
what are your plans linear for them
after this event what I'm going to do
where we will see you next time well I'm
going to to take a break that's for sure
now uh which I was very much looking
forward because it's been a really busy
year for me with the grand chest tour
and the Grand Prix so I have been
playing a lot which also I think took
its toll now in this tournament uh
especially uh the the second half
so I'm planning to take a long break and
probably I'll play the the world rapid
and Blitz event
which is going to be I think in the end
of December as usual so I'll probably
play that but other than that I'll maybe
play something online or something but
just mainly
um mainly resting speaking of rapid and
Blitz we've seen you make your moves
with one second especially in that game
against Sam Serbian what were you trying
to do at that point I don't know I mean
I just I didn't realize I when I saw
that I played with one second I got
scared and then I you scared us as well
yeah no I think that the same that same
evening when I got home I was still
still having a bit of nightmares with
this one second I said my God if I lose
some time this game it just would be
over and it's the end of the tournament
so yeah I don't know I mean I guess you
get a position where you know you you're
never I mean you're pressing and you
will never lose but of course there's a
Time Factor yeah you can lose so I guess
I got too too confident somehow but but
um but yeah that was that was a risky
situation there
a lot of adrenaline in those moments
exactly yeah once again uh
congratulations and a very successful
tournament we wish you all the best in
your career
thank you absolutely oh